is it true or not that you you kept a
lightsaber I officially don't on the
lights a props guy gave me one no I
didn't it we bought some lightsabers no
that was already going on no you have to
know what you're doing with it you do
though is that which one would you like
which one looks like yours the one in
the middle is I think the one I use it
that's that's Alec Guinness is one oh
then it's yours yeah yeah oh my god this
is a really nice so amazing how do you
turn that one bang them against each
other with a break oh no they won't you
make the sound effects yourself do you
want to do one not at all hey go go go
but can you make the noises okay is it
true that you did this thing you guys is
about to dive yeah like in rocket did
this in rocky as well where they had to
you would make the sound effect
yourselves so they had to go back and
like sound was a nightmare because it
was a bunch of people going no it was to
begin with it was quite difficult not to
make the sound yeah and also it goes
away because it makes that nice and Shh
noise when it goes down oh yes I heard
that in rocky they're partly like the
first film particularly it's just lords
of sound effects of surface you're still
all good
[Laughter]
literally you like litter the light
sound let's of lifestyle guess you have
to do you have to start them up okay so
off off how do you do that much they are
there so when you put on it has to make
this turn noise mine keeps going off
there one a twirl it something do it
over here hang on alters here wait wait
who's who you just it's there you go
actually I should be so can you throw a
ball cuz you go you go okay okay we go
all right we're gonna let baseball in
baseball it how's that okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you